[Musique]
azebaze maputo africa lunga lunga azam
derniers jours sud africain pour la
délégation de réunionnais venus
participer aux lèvres ou challenge une
journée marathon accompagné par le
consulat afin de renforcer les liens et
consolider les partenariats initié
l'année dernière tout converge
finalement qu'est-ce que c'est un
travail qui prend du temps qui est un
peu sous terrain et tout converge le
jour dit avec une participation plus
d'élèves de la réunion qui viennent ici
pour faire pour passer une semaine au
cap
donc disons que on est très heureux de
voir que cette débauche concrètement sur
une illustration forte de la coopération
entre la réunion et le cap
un retour positif du consul et l'équipe
se séparent pour optimiser la mission on
arrive à construire d'autres projets
insertion tourisme
vraiment on est dans la construction et
cette construction se fait avec du lien
et ce lien passe aussi par les
ambassades
c'est le centre même de la construction
globale de ce qu'on met en place au
niveau du conseil départemental pour la
réunion à travers l'océan indien et les
peuples de l'océan indien moment ça
mondiale nous famille moment laisse pa
nou tomber
et à part ça bondienne nous famille papa
laisse parler tant que directeur du
musée de villèle espère beaucoup de sa
visite au musée de l'esclavagé
car à la différence des maîtres les
esclaves ont laissé peu de traces
matérielles est exposée dans un musée
dans quelques années on espère que le
musée pourra donner à voir et replacer
l'histoire de la réunion dans une grande
cartographique des pays de la zone et
compris du monde puisqu'il comme tout
n'est les territoires et pays qui ont
connu du soir de l' esclavage s'inscrit
dans un grand récit de l'histoire de
l'esclavagisme donc on espère que le
musée pourra donner ses clés de
compréhension et de replacer l'histoire
de la réunion dans ce qu'il fait
historique de l'histoire d'un esclavage
pendant ce temps une visite est faite
aux trois réunionnais de l'alliance
française dont sa directrice
[Musique]
la discussion est très large
elle parle de coopération bien
évidemment dans le domaine de la culture
dans le monde du sport mais aussi
coopération économique
c'est aussi le moment de parler de
l'insertion puisque à travers l'accueil
des deux contrats celui-ci au niveau de
l'alliance on
on essaie de d'évoquer ensemble des
perspectives d'évolution pour ces
contrats qu'est ce qu'on peut proposer
aux réunionnais qui s'expatrient le
temps de ces contrats à l'étranger
qu'est ce qui fonctionne bien comment
est ce qu'on peut améliorer ces
dispositifs mais c'est de construire
pour l'avenir une relation possible
entre la réunion et ses pays voisins et
en particulier l'afrique du sud
un papa mende et venait à nice à wama
sein d'amundi bp tous les 7 ans mouillé
une journée qui ne pourraient pas se
conclure sans la visite de
l'impressionnant musée d'art moderne le
moka tout l'été chic et ont été
réutilisés par les esclaves
construire
les fondations de cette ce grand six
polonais de calais
[Musique]
ici la thématique de l'esclavagé donne
du sens à beaucoup d'oeuvres alors même
que l'esclavagé - contemporain que la
partie est vraiment ça vous donne cette
ouverture et cette possibilité de
travailler en partenariat avec ce qu'il
ya de mieux faire l'international et
aussi prendre conscience de ce qu'il ya
aussi de très branché retour à la
réunion avec une ambiance spéciale
lundis bleus dans le bus qui sonne
prochaine étape de cette coopération
sportive et culturelle une manifestation
décembre la réunion pour les 170 ans de
l'abolition de l'esclavagé
[Applaudissements]